One of the nice things about feature scaling is that it's
fairly straightforward.
There's a formula, and you just have to apply it to your data.
Here's the formula.
x prime is the new feature that you're making.
And you use information about the old features to figure out
what value it should take.
x min and x max are the minimum and
maximum values that are taken by the old feature before it was rescaled.
And x is the old value of the individual feature that you're rescaling.
So just to make this more concrete, let me give you a quiz.
Suppose the old weights, the feature that we want to rescale, are 115,
140 and 175 pounds.
If this is the old feature, what is x min?
Write your answer in the box.